hey i'm dylan o'brien and i'm here with
buzzfeed to read there's tweets
is this just gonna get insane
i would sell an organ to see dylan
o'brien reading thirst tweets i can live
without one of my kidneys writes that is
right that's actually true so no issues
there whoever decided to give dylan
o'brien a blonde buzz cut i hope your
pillow is cold on both sides and your
phone is always charged
i love the pillow cold on boat side sink
i'm with that that was that's not that's
pretty tame dylan o'brien if you're
reading this i am free until the end of
time oh plenty of time then i don't need
to rush to hang with you the worst part
about blonde dylan o'brien is the fact
that i would date him in a heartbeat
just kind of [ __ ] up
what's wrong with that yeah run
run imagine getting paid to kiss on a
run i do that [ __ ] for free these are
nothing come on give me the real [ __ ]
then ryan is so hard i would let him
guys let gate keep girl boss me any day
i love that one
ah yes all of the manipulative tactics
the [ __ ] thing men can do is to be
blonde dylan o'brien that i want to get
on a t-shirt or underwear can i get that
on underwear the feminine urge to go
completely feral anytime zona ryan
appears on screen
yes let's go
it is wrong to sexualize this celebrity
in any capacity as some statements may
make them uncomfortable and feel awkward
however i would absolutely let blonde
and tattoo dylan o'brien
oh commit commit i would go so far so
mine could still redacted my redacted
and redacted tilly redacted
i love that one okay that one's i think
my favorite so far i love that style
let's contact that one i cannot stress
this enough donald ryan and maze runner
could literally break my back like a
glow stick
i love that one and then it lights up
so brian i'm bowing down on my knees
right now let me wash your feet king let
me scrub and lick between your toes
polish those feet until they shine like
diamonds scrape the dry skin flakes off
and use them as seasoning just to taste
gliese
yeah
holy [ __ ] people are
sick i would really let donald ryan
pluck every one of my eyelashes off no
good come on don't you don't mean that
don't do that i can't express how badly
i need toner brian to sit on my face and
suffocate with that fat ass can we get
my mother in here for this like why is
she not here my
is this a typo my bussy belongs to dylan
o'brien let's go
let's go
oh what i wouldn't give it to you dylan
bryan's entire ass thank you anytime i
get a butt compliment
you're invited to hang this is so
dylan o'brien sir i'm just a hole for
you
the faces in this room
go for it look it's here's i mean my
takeaway is like it's an art and it's an
art that i appreciate i think a couple
made me a gape but like i don't think
there was any that you know
i couldn't handle you know
i love it
i'm gonna make a burner account and do
some my home that was enlightening and
gave me a little
boost for the day to the ego so thank
you guys so much and thank you buzzfeed
and make sure you check out not okay on
hulu the whole for you note of that one
too we will contact them later
[Music]